the World Cup is happening now I've been
watching less maybe than other World
Cups I think partially it's the timezone
situation but I have been watching we
have a new report released in the middle
of the World Cup which has exposed that
FIFA knew about Russian players doping
and did nothing about it
we knew that FIFA was corrupt we knew
the Russians had this habit of using
banned substances and lots of sports
Soccer Olympic sports anything goes for
doping for the Russians what we didn't
know until a couple of days ago was that
FIFA learned about the Russian doping
before it went public and didn't do a
thing about it and according to this new
report by the Mail on Sunday FIFA knew
18 months before the World Cup that
Russian players were doping and they did
nothing we're talking about dozens of
players here dating back to failed drug
tests years ago and FIFA all along was
slow to even look for evidence last
month all 28 players on the Russian
preliminary team were cleared because
FIFA had quote insufficient evidence to
say yes they definitely were doping but
what is now known is that a week before
FIFA cleared the 28 players a 29th
player was removed from the team his
name's Ruslan Campbell ah've and he
failed the drug test in 2015 right after
that his urine sample was swapped for a
clean one no punishment was ever doled
out he was put on the Russian roster
initially and then a week before 28
players were cleared
cama ball off Kemble off' suffered an
injury which immediately raised
questions about why he was really
replaced on the team FIFA has put
together a response to the allegations
the response makes no sense FIFA refused
to answer any questions from The Mail on
Sunday before they published their
investigation and of course FIFA has a
very long history of lying and
corruption and what happened here is
pretty clear the World Cup is in Russia
already that's a signal of corruption
because we know that even the mere
awarding of World Cups is a corrupt
process so you've got the World Cup in
Russia a ton of their players test
positive for doping how do you ban the
team that's hosting the event right it's
just completely politically
untenable yeah so FIFA does what it does
best which is they follow corruption
with more corruption and lies with more
lies and in a sense nothing surprising
happened here FIFA is consistently
mind-blowing numbing ly corrupt Russia
consistently cheats everybody is doing
exactly what they're expected to do well
you know how the host country gets those
perks and privileges like their team is
automatically in tournament the worse
you play the first game maybe this
should just be one of them you get to
get away with doping and it's no problem
what FIFA wants is low controversy and
high revenue and what they're basically
saying is if you're the host team you
get the dope without consequences that
is de facto what they're actually saying
because if they ban the team that's
hosting the World Cup it's not good for
their reputation nor for their revenue
it creates controversy now the next
question becomes should we stop watching
the World Cup in protests and the next
World Cup is in Qatar that's an actual
slave state with Sharia law as their
main source of legislation as per the
Constitution they have flogging and
stoning as forms of legal punishment and
we've spoken to Dave's ayran about this
and Dave's ayran last World Cup I don't
know where he is on this issue this
World Cup said we can still be fans of
the sport and watched the games while
being activists for better working
conditions or against corruption or
whatever and I went along with that
because I want to watch the World Cup
right for myself for my feelings of self
I said you know what Dave's ayran is
right it's fine to watch the world Qatar
it'll call out the problems how much is
too much I mean when the country if you
had a country that killed the workers
that build the stadiums after they built
them would be be ready to say you know
that's a step too far we're now no
longer gonna watch there's no longer
okay to watch the World Cup I don't know
what the answer is but it's starting to
not feel right to watch the World Cup
well there's certainly a market case to
be made here right if FIFA looks at the
ratings and they say that fewer people
wash the Russia World Cup and fewer
people watch the Qatar World Cup match
compared to the past ones maybe we got
to make sure that going forward we're
putting it in countries with actual
ethical governments Yallah seas right
it's possible but at the same time it
might be more roulette
the time zone right of the host country
that impacts ratings significantly we
see that with the Olympics as well I
don't know what the answer is but what I
can tell you is I'm increasingly feeling
not right by just watching these games
and I don't know if others in the
audience are experiencing that and I
love World Cup as much as anybody I
really do but I am unsure about how long
it is even morally acceptable to
participate in this even as a spectator
send me your thoughts today's program is
made possible in part by futur futur is
a social forecasting game where you
compete with other players to predict
the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market a scientifically proven way of
using the wisdom of the crowd to create
more accurate predictions about future
events prediction markets have been
shown to work much better than other
forecasting methods like polling or
expert analysis in many cases and futur
has actually taken the concept and
turned it into a fun easy to use social
game you open up the futur app and
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you can check out my predictions
and follow me to get updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecasts it's free and it's available
on both Android and iOS and right now on
foote or you can win cash prizes for
correct predictions about the World Cup
check it out at fut you you are calm